foreign
[Music]
okay here we are we are doing Lifeline
we have a guest host because my brother
is still sick with covet which is uh you
know bad but he's fine but he's just you
know it's the tail end of it what's that
noise the coffee maker she had to have
coffee guys so we are with instead of
Matt filling in my wife Kristen
so
yay that's nice you didn't clap for
yourself but you're very humble you know
what I mean thank you yeah you are you
can move these two you're like not as
humble I'm not as humble no no but you
know sometimes we all have our strengths
we all have our strengths like yours is
being humble and mine is actual strength
I just have crazy strength
so uh that coffee is too loud can you
hear it you think no all right great
so you already you already ruined it no
we we love we love it that you're here I
love it that you're here actually
because here's why because we had Brian
Callan on and Matt uh when Matt was
first sick then I was we were having a
baby yeah which by the way
congratulations to us we had our baby
William
McHenry Dalia who is so cute he's very
cute he's actually here on a uh boppy's
laying down over there but
um
he is uh here and so is Calvin we've got
the whole family here but we the reason
why you're here is because metsec but we
were going to but uh and so the reason
why we wanted you to come is because
Brian came and it was like so much
testosterone and then Matt was here and
it was just him and so we wanted a
female to get a female perspective on
these a lot of these uh
uh advices I think that's smart but I
think me and Kelly in general is smart
yeah oh okay no I thought I was seeing
you oh yeah yeah I think me and Callan
have like a very similar Vibe oh yeah
totally completely yeah yeah you know
totally because we're both flamboyant
I would never say you're flim boy and
actually he's way more flamboyant than
you are so
um but yeah so we did have the baby and
it was very nice and he's very healthy
and he's got and he's brunette and
Calvin's blonde and that's cute so cute
what do you think about being a mom it's
for to double
isn't it weird to say kids yeah that's
my weirdest part
I know I know it like makes it seem not
as cool I know I know but we have to
remember we're still very very cool
especially me man when I walk like dude
come on oh
this isn't my only pair of sunglasses
either oh I have green ones and I've
read one it only took you like two
minutes to to not be humble well just to
put them on well we all have our
strengths right yeah yeah but um so
anyway what what how do you feeling
about your tummy and all that what
happened awesome yeah well I mean I just
yeah postpartum depression I mean you
know just like let's get right into fire
holy I'm just giving you stuff to you
know fodder do you have postpartum
depression
so rude well maybe I don't know what's
up what's been on your mind there's like
different
things that you can have you can have
full-blown postpartum which I've never
had and then most women have baby blues
oh which is this like up and down up and
down and that's kind of definitely what
I have oh really yeah but that's not
that doesn't sound medical baby blues
I don't know that's just what they call
it the doctor just like there's like you
get the blues like that right you know
they also have sunglasses and there's
some so many amazing parts of being a
mom for the second time and
but the the biggest downside
is I have this thing called Demers
which is whenever I start it up now you
could look it up I swear it's real and
whenever I start breastfeeding thank you
um I
feel existential dread right and like I
want to off myself okay well that's
straight up okay you want to eat it
yourself yeah I want to ski myself into
Oblivion isn't it so weird and it's like
this beautiful thing I'm holding this
child that I love more than life itself
I would throw myself in front of a bus
happily happily
[Laughter]
and then I'm just feeling this like
everything sucks I suck every everyone
says it's crazy that just because your
nipples are squirting you want to eat
yourself don't say squirting when it
comes to my nipples
I was so mad we were watching or I was
watching congratulations yeah I make her
do it this password are you caught up
well you were like talking no I did not
want to watch it actually you wanted to
watch it because of the pregnant because
I was talking about the preg the uh the
birth yeah I knew you were talking about
that yeah and the amount of different
nicknames that you called my vagina
was atrocious well there were maybe five
different ones yeah like just the fact
that fried butterfly came out of your
mouth
your wife I'm your wife I know but I had
to but I was okay well but I have to say
that though because otherwise we'll get
demonetized and if I want to say vaginas
like I'm not a I'm not a you know what I
mean Christopher doctor okay fried
butterfly is great because they don't
demonetize that okay that's one thing if
there was just one they do look like
fried butterflies if you're going to be
brutally honest not yours specifically
but I'm just saying first of all why do
we have to be brutally honest because
this is a hard hit this is Lifeline dude
okay but also it'd be one thing if you
just switched out one name you gave my
vagina you could say vagina okay I'm not
a clinician so I'm not okay you gave us
a hatchet wound
I know it's but it's okay because you
don't look demonetized right yeah well
that's my point is you gave it like
eight different nicknames and just went
what you do drilled the joke into the
ground until there was absolutely no
life left and it took like two minutes
and it was insane nappy Dugout oh my God
talking to the microphone please
um so yeah that's what's up nappy Dugout
I think um
I can't remember where I got that from
that's so disgusting wow but that's life
dude it's beautiful and disgusting at
the same time
so we have a baby he was very purple
when he came out huh did you get what
were you worried no I wasn't you were I
could tell that you were worried but a
little bit
um I was listening to the doctors and
the nurses and you're kind of always on
alert for people to be
um lying to you and [__] you over so
even when they were like no it's totally
fine a normal you were like it's not
yeah and I could tell you were doing
that because you know why because they
do the thing where it's like were you
like is that normal and they'll be like
yeah and you're like oh seven notes in
there so you're lying
seven notes in there so you're lying
look at this nappy duck it's saying for
a woman's vagina it doesn't matter the
color of the woman or the amount of hair
presumably some hair if you are being
literal made famous by George Clinton
and the Funkadelics I hate it there's
like the possibility of just like now
worth is where I heard it a screenshot
like you can screw there's gonna be a
thing of me on the internet of just me
with that well there is now definition
yeah that's what I mean there wouldn't
have been what oh yeah [__] it's okay
you got to learn about that I'm new to
the internet game yeah okay so uh look
uh we got uh I'm gonna be uh so Lifeline
you've got a question go to watch
lifeline.com and uh send in a video if
you want one-on-one of my sessions with
macro to matalia.com we have new
Lifeline merch at lifelinemerch.com and
then also I'm gonna be on tour I got a
lot of different dates coming up I'm
going to be in Columbus Cincinnati uh
Salt Lake City Tucson I'm gonna be in uh
Pueblo Colorado and Colorado Springs and
I'm gonna be in a bunch of different
things uh a bunch of different cities uh
in Canada
Nashville
hotline is open
the hotline is open you can just go and
call and leave a message for uh what you
can do that instead of leave a video and
the number is 213
-973-8095 call today and you you know
I'm sure they'll put on the thing there
you can just screenshot it um
so yeah so well we talked about a lot of
stuff so far but let's get into the uh
advice because I want to say you know
you're a female and I want to get the
female perspective on this that's
well all right babe you know I I
honestly it's not that I don't want the
female perspective I don't want
anybody's perspective period yeah I
already have the perspective for me
that's what works the perspective like
capital for me yeah for me I have my
perspective but you do force it on to
other people's perspective yeah I go
like this no no that's not how it is
it's like this right right okay okay
fair enough
me me
no I'm in my I just finished my first
year of my three years of grading either
I'm not a psychologist either but yeah I
feel like you did nine months of college
yeah at theater School NYU
hated it yeah hated it not for you we
had a breathing class so I'm all good
I'm all good a breathing class a [__]
class for breathing God you [__]
needed that I wish you I wish you took
that until my contact fell out
um and went on the ground and I was
looking for it and the teacher walked
right across the space I was looking at
and I almost
[Laughter]
hip thrower
that couldn't happen because there's
nobody on the planet that rude she did
do that
and then she and yeah she was a teacher
teaching Breath class
and I was so mad and that I was like I'm
gonna be in I'm going to be on TV
because this [__] I'm gonna show this
woman I'm gonna be on TV
I don't need Breath class
think of something that you would be
more pissed off at yeah I know like if I
did that
what like if if we were in our house oh
my God I mean you'd already started
crying because you know I'd be mad yeah
well I just would never hear at the end
what the [__] you walk right in front of
the thing check your bottom of your
souls
you're a that's not my fault if somebody
walks across and I'm doing looking for
my contacts that's so rude dude if you
if someone's down on the ground like
this and you walk across you're a piece
of [__] dude
that's it you're not gonna say anything
about that I just I mean there's so many
different ways I could go with that that
um
and every single way that I would go
would just mean that you're an insane
person me yeah
because I'm looking for my contact
information how is everybody else in the
world supposed to be attuned to the fact
that like that's what you're doing she
did always on purpose it was 100 on
purpose everyone knew I was looking for
my contact and she did it Christopher
guys I lost my contact keep breathing
but I gotta go look for my contact and
I'm gonna work my breathing while I'm
looking for my contact over here
everybody was chill and then we go there
and I was like
and she just can't she clopped over dude
I'm so I'm angry now again you you
announced to the breathing class that
you had to find your contact
yeah you
you are you sweetheart I am me you are
you anyway I still have contacts and
she's you know I was probably 70 now so
all right let's look at the next one
the first one
[Laughter]
I saw you in like 2018 2019 but it's
been too long hi Matt I love the podcast
and I love you guys together
um I have something really random it
happened to me like two months ago but I
still think about it almost every single
day
um long story short I got into a car
accident they did my car total loss I
get a new car and then I go to the tag
agency to get it registered
get there get the little ticket with the
number the girl calls my number she's as
Cuban as can be as am I so then I tell
her in Spanish
and her response to that without
exaggerating was
okay and I just say it's staring at her
confused for like three seconds and then
some girl walks in and she's like well I
was helping her before you and I was
just like take your time and then the
girl that works next to her ended up
being the one that helped me so
everything happens for a reason but what
should I have said what should I have
done I've never had anyone be just so
rude to me what did you say that so I
just stayed like
like that
what on his customer service
that's good she did that
yeah woohoo
oh you're saying the customer service
person it's good that she did that yeah
okay explain sweetheart well because
she's not this is not the whole story
she just you know call someone and say
hi so I'm trying to check out about my
car
I am I'm trying to go check out about my
car that is insane and if that happened
that is the most gangster [__] of all
time and I am through if only the other
car on the other phone here's the deal
I'm on the other phone I'm on the phone
call about something they're gonna [__]
it up they're gonna [__] it up you know
people [__] [__] up people don't want
their jobs they're just like I got this
job I need to make money that's fine
people don't want to do it so they're
already gonna [__] up if you just
immediately go to mach 10 of I'm gonna
be a dick I go oh all right fair game
now I get to be a dick right hey what's
up I'm trying to figure out about my car
hey what's up I'm getting pick up my my
car all right oh all right oh what's up
dude
what's up man are we getting this
through Insurance are we doing it out of
pocket let me know dude how much is it
gonna [__] be that's awesome because
then we're ready we're off gloves are
off and we're going so this she should
have thanked the lady and been like here
we go
or whatever the [__] you know I don't
know what the [__]
wow well what do you think well I don't
really have any advice for her because
what would you have done uh cried ran
scream cried and ran like well any
confrontation with anybody that's
working that like is doing a service for
me there's nothing that they could do
that I won't be nice dude that's what we
don't get we don't connect on this yeah
because you go like this don't be don't
be and I'm like this person is asking
for it yeah and I'm sure that the middle
is like the happiest place it's not
dappy's place the happiest place it's
the angriest place which is where I'm
going to live sure you know what this
reminds me of though
when I was pregnant with Cal this it
makes sense that this is how you feel
when I was pregnant with Cal I had some
kind of thing in the middle of the night
that we woke up and I was having like
intense tummy pain and so you and me
went to the hospital the hospital
and we were there I wanted to stop and
get a coffee on the way but yeah
probably we were there for hours and
hours and hours and it was just like
draining and long and then as we're
leaving and we're both just so tired and
just like stressed I press the elevator
button yeah yes yes and you were like
what floor is it and I was like I think
it's the third floor and Chris goes
that's right I did do that
I was pregnant at the hospital for no
reason
and everything wow but it did make me
laugh harder than I've ever so hard I
love so much and you laughed hard and I
felt so good and it was worth it and now
we have now what do we have we have that
core memory don't we yeah so you're
welcome and two beautiful babies I know
you're welcome for that okay I did part
of it you did a lot more man it's crazy
how much the women the woman does for
the birth thing and guys don't really do
anything every matter of fact guys do
pretty much the fun part guys just go
we're women nine ten months it's not
even not nine months ten months just
women just 10 months of
walking around bending over the baby's
hanging it's all out you know what I
mean
how long do you think you could last
before eating myself
just like pregnant in general
I wouldn't get pregnant dude no but if
you were
I'd eat it
don't say that babe
[Music]
that makes it more personal I need it
I hope that that was good advice for her
all right yeah I don't know just hang up
dude it's all good you're good
next one wow I'm gonna get right okay no
I'm having a big problem you know I'm
I'm 21. tall drink of water six seven
whatever it is but
I'm having a problem
distinguishing what I want between
doinkin
yeah and having a girlfriend because you
know like I have I have some good
candidates in my life wow that could be
some good good long-term or or nice
Partners but since I'm young and
especially with the friend group I have
who are also doinking a lot I I'm just
wondering should I take this time maybe
push off or
or miss out on the opportunity to have
this nice long-term girlfriend to doink
around a little bit
you know I don't know maybe these
questions for Chris because he's had
some experience or met too you could you
could help me out a little bit with your
your Buddha advice but but I just want
to know should I doink or should I
settle down I mean settle down a guy's
[__] 21 Google what do you think
um
I had a buddy that used to say that all
the time oh man he's a slore wow go
ahead I mean obviously he needs to be
doinking right why you say that
one [__] who cares right yeah like
have fun and doing you know get your
doinking out of the way right so that
you don't end up like there's no such
thing getting the doinking out of the
way by the way well there's not there's
you because you need to stop you need to
you just need to live life and you need
to play it as it happens dude I don't
think that like I mean there's people
that were together since they were 21
and they're happy as as all get out you
know but you're 21 that's young the guy
looks
you were 21 when you met your first wife
right no
like 22. no I got married at 20
six or yeah so that's yeah she was 21. I
was 26. I'm I met her way early on
though like you know when when I was a
kid yeah it was cute didn't work out and
so um but the uh but this dude should be
yeah he should be don't get I mean dude
do you feel lonely I mean the fact that
you're even asking this question do you
what when you find you'll find the
person that you want to be with you're
not going to be like oh I have some
candidates oh yeah I have a few good you
know
I have some FR I have a front runner and
like you're just gonna know it's gonna
be so apparent these people who are like
yeah I don't understand like the dating
around and then choosing one you just
know when you know don't you don't you
feel that way for sure uh yeah okay yeah
for sure
how many like serious girlfriends have
you had that you felt that way about
that you like stopped doinking well I
don't really stop doing it
um you made them your girlfriends never
really stopped doing
um uh I made them my girlfriend and they
made me their boyfriend I mean
um having a stroke four
yeah that you were like this is the one
that I'm gonna yes try to not doink
anymore with it okay yeah yeah I think
I'm about the same but I wasn't really
like actively doinking right you weren't
really slowing it up we make a joke but
you weren't really slowing it up no you
weren't always on your back in college
right
I'm saying you I'm saying you warrant
always right you weren't always getting
a butterfly inspection right not always
right help SOS all right yeah so stay
stay doinking brother
I'm Hulk Hogan
yeah
amen Chris a long time listener you guys
always make me smile on my worst days
and today is one of my worst days oh I
am wondering how you still feel worthy
when you tell someone that you love that
you want a lifelong future with them and
start a family with them and they tell
you that their career needs to come
first and that until they have their
dream job and and all the money in the
world that you can't have that with them
um I'm wondering what you do
and how to still feel worthy and like
you're good enough and I like just I
don't know what I do so any advice would
be great thank you oh
sad
um go ahead no you should take this why
because I just want to see where you're
gonna go oh [__] I'm gonna get in
trouble dude I know I'm kidding
um well first of all you are worthy this
is all stuff that like you live with in
your head the tapes that play in your
head ever since you were a young child
you know you you don't need someone else
to make yourself feel worthy and if you
think you do they're doing you a favor
by not giving you that because you know
that then you run into like codependence
and and [__] like that which I'm good I
promise but it's like you know you you
you you you you get your value in
someone getting your value in someone
else is something that isn't going to
help you be uh figure out your [__] you
know
um and yeah you could live life like
that and always be looking for
Acceptance in others I do but um
it's not gonna be it's not gonna be the
best version of you that you can be
um I understand you're upset also here's
the other thing uh the person that's
saying this uh I was that guy saying my
career is the most important for a man
for a man it's very hard to
relinquish that
feeling of if I am I I I'm worthy
because of my
output in work or what I do uh in my job
you know how much money I make what kind
of impression I leave with my work
that's where guys get their self-worth
from but that's also something that
a guy shouldn't be carried away with
shouldn't get carried away with just as
in you're talking about as you're
getting yourself carried away with by
wanting someone else to make you feel
worthy that's one thing it's sad because
you both want different things and
that's just going to be the way it is
not necessarily what not necessarily
what that they want different things
right but which is what I was just going
to say is that he may come around right
and he also it sounds like he does want
to be with you but just not that doesn't
want to make that huge commitment
because his work is something that he
really wants to do which for a young guy
I totally get that I really do totally
get that well I think what you were
saying about men finding their worth and
what they're doing their job yeah I
think
maybe follow up and get more information
from him because it sounds like
it may not be something where
maybe he thought that you were like I
need to give up everything I need to
give up my dream my game my game
whatever to just be with her and not
might not necessarily be the truth and I
think guys too have like a knee-jerk
reaction when they get oh definitely I
do what to do especially around work so
maybe just asking him
I'm a little unclear are you saying that
you want
a family eventually or are you saying
that your career is always going to be
the most important or or do you see that
shifting at all and if he's like
straight up I don't see that shifting
yeah then you have your answer right
right true yeah and that's when you have
to dig deep in yourself and say I know
who I am
I'm worthy of this and I have to walk
away from this relationship to get what
I need yeah which is really [__] hard
and like you know put a bunch of lye on
his plants and this way they all die and
then this way you're even yeah
um yeah no I do I do uh that that's
that's a tough position though but also
you're young and I'm sure he's young he
I chances are
I mean look I working was the most
important thing to me and now I have a
family and it's just not anymore you
know well when we first started dating I
told you that yeah yeah and I was like
that's totally cool with me it was
before we were serious and as the
relationship progressed and we like hit
different stages we would have new
conversations that kind of like redrew
the lines yeah like you don't it doesn't
always have to be yeah like a
relationship is fluid and it shifts yeah
as you guys should yeah so but that also
doesn't mean especially for women yeah
no it's cool it's cool you're later it's
not cool anymore
wow but yeah I don't know yeah like yeah
no that's cool yeah I'll do the those
things yeah and then I'll clean up the
dishes and then oh hey by the way that's
your job but you're in
yeah
oh we have fun now dude um I it's a it's
okay to change your mind yes and it's
okay to there's been plenty of times
where I was like I was okay with
something at first of course yeah and
then I had a full-blown breakdown and
was like never mind yep not okay with
that anymore okay so okay all right cool
so then I go like this well you
Hoodwinked me didn't you oh you Hood
winked me but it's okay man love is
being Hoodwinked next one
upside down
very obvious
serious case of upside down head okay
what do you guys think I should do about
it
honestly kind of think about getting in
the wigs
I think that'd be cool I think it's kind
of like a tattoo you know it's just
decoration
said it weird all good emphasis was on
the wrong part of the word we're gonna
move on so you know it's not an
insecurity thing I'm
sure of myself okay I got shoulders that
go into next week I'm [__] yattted
out okay fine okay it's a deeper Mark
Baron with no hair let me know you guys
thoughts get get thoughts on what what
that's on what what I miss he's saying
what what should I do should I get a
good what should I do with my hair I got
upside down head what do I do
I I understand that was ingest he's not
gonna wear a wig which by the way would
be gangster but get a different color
than your beard
that would be so awesome well is that
the question yeah I don't think he's
actually gonna get wigs I think the
question is what do I do I have upside
down head I think that that's the actual
question and then he said you think it's
sexy to have upside down head well I
mean you call it upside down head but
what it is is it's just being bald and
having facial hair did you think that's
sexy yeah
he's not sexy it could be sexy if the
guy's sexy here's the thing yeah and
well you wanted to hear the female yeah
you're right go ahead like and I know
that your hair is like something that
you talk about is like something that
you're
you like worry about what about worry
about like yeah if like it looks bad or
some [__] of course yeah yeah yeah girls
don't care sometimes my hair looks
[__] bad though it's like I put
product in it and it's like it I thought
it looked one way leaving the house and
then I look later and I'm like what the
[__] they just truly don't care about
that [__] it's just like how you're
rocking it and if you like come in and
it's insane and you're sure in your body
and you just take control of the space
yeah like that hair oddly becomes like
even sexier than if it looked nice
because it's like wow that guy with the
weird [__] hair doesn't give a [__]
no you're supposed to keep talking oh
dude I I think yeah I don't really get I
don't give a [__] you know oh
I'm the man when I walk into a room all
right dude well that's the point though
like rock what you have yeah I think and
I think he's handsome yeah yeah he's
he's he seems sure of himself yeah yeah
that's the most important thing the most
important thing is that upside down head
is just a joke you know it doesn't
really matter if you have upside down
head I personally don't like upside down
head I think it's weird I think you look
bad but you know what I mean like you
don't want me to think you [__] don't
look bad you want [__] chicks to
think you don't look bad so you can do
the horizontal Mambo more right and do
some butterfly inspections oh
um inspections yeah so I so I think that
I I like this I like this guy I think he
seems cool yeah he's got it up also
here's another thing you could do if
you're gonna get a wig get a [__] wig
that's a different color than your beard
it looks like you had a little brown or
red in it dude get a black John Wick wig
or or like the lady from 227 that goes
like this maybe like that that that hair
or a [__] straight up blonde wig that
like guile from Street Fighter 2 would
wear that would be awesome book so
here's the other thing you could do dude
you're added up get you at it on the
[__] Dome piece man no get a huge
spider web what nose nose really
I bet you'd like that if my hair went
and it might and then I got yattted up
no like a yamaka no
I don't know man I don't know man you
added up like a yamaka like like that
like Jewish but also like like Jewish
but like oh but he's been through yeah
but here's the thing who who stole his
menorah
you're but we're talking about like
standing in yourself and having like
being firm at who you are knowing that
like you're a guy that's like oh [__] I
might lose my hair yeah and then if you
were to take the step yeah to do some
weird free space [__] I'd be like oh man
he [__] caved no I didn't say when
you're like when you are like oh man
that guy got plugs that sucks that's
terrible that's the same [__] no it's
not because then it's an open canvas
you're like let's have some fun with it
and then you get yattted up
you're just saying words no I'm saying
the words that matter in the order that
I want to say them in
I think you should get a Jesus crown
like a Thorns like Thorns around like
that
and above that those those swervy
streets in San Francisco oh yeah yeah a
little baby trolley but no but okay I'm
back on board yeah exactly you would
love to decorate it like that she would
decorate my head like Christmas yeah I'd
hot glued yeah like gems yep you'd put a
little Halo with it it would be
and a halo for an angel and then trees
and then Santa would be fun yeah well
for for the holidays I'd put little
balls in the trees yeah yeah for sure uh
but also so do that don't get plugs
never get plugged never get plugged my
hair goes it's going would you just
shave it
it's also not going I know I don't think
it is but I mean it's definitely further
back than it was but that's just what
happened yeah yeah you know whatever if
it goes It goes yeah [__]
I think I I you know I don't know I know
people some of my friends got plugs I'm
like why'd you even need to get them you
look as handsome as ever thank you very
much darling
um oh wow
I looked the best when I was maybe 30
8.
were we dating then yeah yeah we were we
met when you were 36. I don't remember
okay
let's do the next one okay
quick question
when I'm watching a movie with my wife
or friends or something nice
and they're on their phone
I get super aggravated
internally it's it boils but I'm like I
know this is stupid why do I care that
they're on the phone it's not because I
can see it over there it's more like
they're not sharing this you want to
share the experience you can't really
talk about it or they're missing stuff
100 I feel like I'm kind of crazy with
this one and I'm all alone like but what
do you guys think somebody on the phone
next to you when you're trying to watch
something
um
let me let me hear if I'm crazy or if uh
if you guys are crazy with me
ciao
you got some nerve my friend
dude you want to talk about the phone
yeah I'm bad with the phone but you be
tick-tocking when we're trying to watch
some [__] really good four-part
miniseries sweetheart if we're gonna
separate between which is more annoying
being on the phone during like moments
of
like beautiful family time or just
beautiful lifetime versus some dumb
Netflix series that you admit oh this is
gonna be terrible
which is the better I want to share the
terribleness funniness with you yeah but
I want to share the Beautiful Moments I
understand our couple ship and our
family together it's weird to check out
though when you're what when you're
chilling and you're experiencing life
great we got
um Calvin we got William all of us were
hanging out
I get it sometimes we're hanging out I
feel too much I gotta check out do some
[__] and then okay I'll put it down
whatever but if we're
checking out already putting on the four
part dog [__] miniseries that's gonna be
dope right and we're already checking
out with the dog [__] miniseries and
then you're here scrolling on to and I
gotta hear [__]
yeah mini fridge Life mini like [__]
that you don't even give a [__] about
well I don't check it out already here
you can't check out twice I don't give a
[__] more about the dog [__] miniseries
and at least there's a chance that some
things that's gonna come up is going to
pique my interest other than dog [__]
that's a good argument
I don't know man I get it it's about the
shared experience I wish sometimes you'd
watch stuff with me yeah like dude we'll
turn on like a grade A good thing like
Boardwalk Empire we'll watch one episode
and then the second episode I'm watching
and you're half watching and then you're
like how many do we watch in one night
and then the next night I'm like let's
watch Boardwalk Empire again and you're
like we just watched it last night and
I'm like do you know what binging is
dude
it goes to Something in My Soul that
like if I feel like I'm doing something
unproductive for too long then I'm doing
a disservice to myself you're on Tick
Tock I know but at least there's like
things that I'm learning I'm like oh sea
turtles live to be a thousand or
whatever like that's a new thing that I
learned what was that one you saw
recently no I just made it I don't need
to look at Tick Tock you don't need to
be in the sea turtle Tick Tock but it's
not even Tick Tock you say tick tock I'm
not it's not it's not it's not necessary
I typically check out to like my email
or Pinterest yeah I should do Pinterest
like a [__] dude just like
pinning [__] walls in a church or
something you love to pin
nah nah I I did I got a Pinterest
because I wanted to look at tattoos I
will say though that I know how
important it is to you and that it's
something that I'm willing to compromise
for the um
sanctity of our relationship ladies and
gentlemen we got them
because I know it it I mean you complain
about it daily gentlemen we got her but
you don't like watching binding you
don't like watching TV in the bed
yes that is true this you want to watch
TV in the bed like it's a movie theater
you want to watch TV in the bed dude I
watch TV I don't watch TV in the bed a
bed is for two things no it's not
sleeping and doinking no it's not and if
you're you want to say
be creative I
so what is creative in bed then it's not
living in a box it's the world is your
oyster you can do whatever you want in
that bed it's a big soft
it's a big soft it's a big soft where
anything finish the sentence a big soft
it's a big soft I mean that's the most
beautiful thing a big soft to be in a
big soft
with such an idiot with your love
watching stuff don't be in a big soft
With Your Love
but the first two years that we dated
that's all we did because we got to know
each other and you weren't Tick Tock
wasn't even created
oh
I don't know can you help me do
something oh
um yeah so I don't know we got
we will ask the do you think that leave
a comment in the thing do you think a
bed is for just sleeping and doinking or
do you think that a bed is also for
walking hanging out really yeah lounging
lounging dude talking I want to be in
bed when it's time to sleep or doink
I don't want to be in bed when there's
like three hours left in my day
because you
use Duncan so much I mean
[Laughter]
Donuts Donkey Kong in so much no what is
it because you used to be doinking so
much and then you have like a PTSD
response when you're in the bed and
you're not drinking
I mean I said that in jest but yeah no I
don't know who knows dude yeah who
[__] knows I don't know [__] about
[__] all right well
all right
fine you know
all right let's go to the next one
I'm so excited to have a really good
question to send
it so um
and I live in a normal average city in
New York and I don't want to say exactly
where
um
I live in a nice middle class
neighborhood like people walk their dogs
a lot there's traffic but it's not you
know too terrible
I have a neighbor who keeps putting
mothballs on a sidewalk he's done it for
years
um he puts more moth balls out in the
spring less mothballs out in the fall
but they will spread it across his
entire sidewalk like all the property
what that's his is covered in my
mothballs and I've looked this up and
apparently it's terrible for the
environment and it gets into the water
and I don't know I don't know what to do
because he's a little bit scary and
what's weird what's especially weird
about the situation is that he's my
father he is the brother of a reality
star
um
a famous reality star from the like
early days of reality and again I can't
say okay okay
um so that makes this worse because I
know him per like I just I don't know
what to say to my weird neighbor about
the mothballs because he's a little
scary and he's like I got connections so
what would you do okay how do we get
this guy to stop it's not good for my
dog's Paws it's not good for the
environment it looks bad oh and I didn't
even mention the smell moth boss moth
yeah in your neighborhood open your
window and then you smell it it is so
weird I've never heard of anyone using
mothballs for like pest repellent or
whatever what is he using it for help me
out guys I love how much she's thinking
about this and how deeply she's thinking
about this and I have good advice okay
what's the advice wait it out because if
there's that many mothballs outside of
his house he's definitely flooding his
house with mothball balls and I give
them six months before he croaks of
cancer
not really and then and then the problem
evaporates why does he put mothballs on
his sidewalk
oh man
and people probably on his sidewalk yeah
I mean she said it was on his sidewalk
dude it's a sidewalk
get John Wick
this is uh
here's me hey oh glad I call you what's
going on
what are you doing
that's a sidewalk
I don't like this and this is crazy dude
you know you gotta understand even if
you're not crazy that's gonna make it
seem like it so don't have that
you know what I would do well I would be
like oh uh you have mothballs and then
I'd pick one up and be like it's really
nice have a great day yeah yeah you
would
and now I will be so mad because now I
gotta you'd be like no I don't I this is
a weird thing that's a weird thing it
seems Honestly though like being for
real that's like probably a sign of some
kind of mental mental illness and like
maybe he's like a Batman villain I mean
but mental illness isn't always like
scary and bad and crazy because of the
moth stuff not for sure oh I see yeah I
mean he obviously has Mentos he's just
at home just saying can't wait to get
out there and cover the sidewalk with
moss first my sidewalk and then the
whole small city in New York somewhere
hello ma'am am I annoying you yet
well yeah that's good advice I don't
know about the advice just well if maybe
it's too crazy to touch maybe just go
yeah that's a good yeah it's too crazy
to touch maybe calling an authority at
that point you can just be like it's a
hazard everyone is freaked out
something's going on maybe oh maybe he
has dead bodies
if he has to put mothballs in the front
giveaway you know but I mean you're not
going to smell the dead bodies I know
but like you might as well put a sign up
that says no dead bodies here if he has
mothballs no if he has dead bodies I'm
saying the [__] mothballs is like
like it's too obvious that it was
definitely not that bad yeah but if
you're a guy that has dead bodies in his
house you're not thinking like a clear
rational saying okay fair enough so
I think that whole thing sucks just move
to a different little town in New York
will you say that if you see a spider in
our house so you have a low standard for
him spider uh I was touching spiders the
other day because of Calvin what do you
mean touching
spider webs because he was like I don't
want that but I know I'm too scared and
I was like nah but it's nothing here
come look do it and then I did and he
was able to do it and then I couldn't
believe I was doing it you know what one
of my
um most proud
reactions that I have towards your
dading is what is you're someone that
generally doesn't do things outside of
your comfort zone outside of the box
yeah but when it comes to Cal and you
see him doing the same stuff yeah he's
very similar to you yeah and not wanting
to do things that he's not comfortable
with yeah and you push him in such a
kind and sweet way and you do it too I
do what oh I end up did you put yourself
too I know because of him yeah it rocks
yeah yeah teaching him but really in
reality maybe he's teaching me too right
it's really sweet actually yeah you're a
good dad I yeah I I am yeah math boss no
all right next one
I'm coming at you with a dating
um I'm currently an eating disorder
recovery I have been for about three
months now
um I'm in treatment five days a week six
hours each day can't even work full time
right now good for you I'm healthy I'm
on the men things are going well good
um I have a question so I went on a
first date last night uh things went
really well I really like the guy
um he kept asking me super common yeah
questions about you know House of my
time how to spend my weekends questions
about Works things like that
um I kept trying to tactfully avoid
bringing up treatment because who wants
to talk about it on the first date right
yeah but um I realized I ended up
sounding more sketchy than anything
because of how big I was being so I told
him he was super gracious we didn't
spend a ton of time on it moved right
along I want to know from your
perspective am I a huge red flag
um does that come across like too
personal too fast what do you think love
you guys bye no she said it exactly
right like she didn't want it to seem
weird so she was like I guess I gotta
say it I mean look it's one thing if you
weren't going five days a week for six
hours a day and you just brought it up
because you're in recovery right now
you're in an active you're an active
recovery like trying to get better and
that's great by the way I applaud you
for it I know we both do but like uh you
know if you were on a date with somebody
and you had a better handle on your
addiction and then we're just bringing
it up out of nowhere you might want to
wait two or three dates on it or more I
don't know but
I get the want to be like
because here's the other thing too
uh
right now you know you're in the first
three months like you want to avoid
triggers
for relapse and for making a mess of
your life I think dating is probably
something that they would tell you to
avoid although
I don't know I mean they I I certainly
the rehab I went to and like I know
other rehabs I know like a lot of like
people who are in AAA they have that
same kind of a thing it's like just make
this the main focus on your life
um so they might argue don't go on dates
but you s you know I think you I think
you did the right thing if you know
because I think that it's look I would
get it if if I was sitting with you and
you were like dancing around [__] I
would be like this is a weird chick but
then if you were to say
yeah I I think I'm being vague I want to
not be vague I've been in recovery and
this is why like I don't like I'm not
talking about my job because I'm not
going to my job because I've I would I
would personally
still go out with you I would say I
would say okay well that it's very sweet
she was honest we all have our [__]
um and any other guy that might not
either isn't worth it or might just be
like
not one not wanting that now and that's
okay too you know that's okay if
somebody doesn't want that now
um in their life if they're not ready
for something like that yeah well I
think you make a good point about
like the not dating thing yeah like when
you came out of rehab there were so many
things that you couldn't do like
innocuous but it makes sense now and
that being said like if you are going on
dates then the guy probably has to be
a guy if you want to continue to date
him that is going to be actively
supporting your recovery anyways that's
true and so if he's just like even
avoidant of it then maybe that's not
yeah you know because this is this time
is for you
and like post rehab or post whatever she
went to yeah this time is like for you
to heal and
do whatever you need to do within
yourself to make sure that you're okay
and so by proxy whoever you're with
whoever you end up with needs to be like
totally on your team
because that's no it's no joke you know
like
getting help which is
[__] amazing by the way yeah it's
also really cool it's hard to get help
by the way yeah it is and it's also
really cool how uh open and honesty is
just about it with us totally people now
that we'll see this on the internet and
it's good and it inspires people also to
get help and that's great uh you're
doing the thing and it's [__] tough
man there was a one where I went uh
there was a an Overeaters uh Branch or
whatever on it and they were saying that
that's like some of the hardest
um that's the hardest one one of the
hardest ones to try and figure out so is
it just because food is you need food
and like interesting yeah and it's just
yeah I mean yeah there were some people
actually in even in mind that had it so
Eating Disorders well props to you girl
I'm not a girl
her yeah yeah we have people in our life
that have are in recovery and people
that should be in you know yeah yeah
yeah that don't so we know how hard it
is obviously and that rocks yeah
yeah
uh next one
so we got a question
um lost my mask a long time ago where is
it you can tell I'm a carpenter this is
what I do well you need actually uh to
cover this you started my own business
tight
that our family wants us to move back to
California and we told them we moved
back wow but
the problem is
we don't want to now and we don't know
how to tell them that
uh uh we live in Spokane Washington wow
and we want to move to Tulsa Oklahoma
Jesus Christ so uh telling our family we
want to move to somewhere that gets
tornadoes is
hard enough but yeah what is your advice
how do I
how do I tell them how do we tell them
how do we
I'll let them down
um yeah anything would help thank you
guys love your show bye thanks dude
this has been an issue in my life too
like disappointing family members
because of doing stuff that you need to
do and what to do that's pretty common
it's yeah I think it's common and I
think it's pretty much called having a
family yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um I think you have to like I know you
stated that you don't want to disappoint
them yeah and the it's inevitable that
you are going to disappoint them and so
the thing that you have to work on is
actually just getting okay with
disappointing the people that you love
if it's in the name of doing something
that's better for you and your family
that you have
and I know how hard it can be you know
doing something that you know is going
to
hurt them even if it's not something
like directly towards them but just
something that they're not gonna like
you just have to figure out who you want
to be but you want your personal family
to be and it sucks but you have to do
what you here's here's the thing like I
love Calvin and William and when they
grow up if they want to live somewhere
else I obviously want to be close to
them but also
I I want them to be happy most so I
would I would be like okay I get it but
some like you know especially in the old
it's old school old school [__] is like
you know yeah but it's kind of up to the
parents then to do some [__] if you want
to move to be around them if if you want
that you know yeah I get it if you don't
but like I mean I wouldn't if I was
[__] 70 I would move who gives a [__]
if Calvin and William were somewhere and
they and they were like yeah come move
here we want to be here I would do it
yeah but is that healthy either it is if
you guys all want to
yeah well I'm just saying like if if
Calvin and William are like nah you be
in La then okay yeah I get that I'm
gonna be no I'm coming like but yeah
um I think separation is healthy yeah of
course it is what you have to do you
know uh yeah yeah it's actually one of
the it's really tough it's just one of
the parts of life that's just kind of
hard I I mean I I I think that you
should basically keep making chairs and
and bring the chairs to Tulsa and make
chairs in Tulsa dude also let me tell
you something I want to well I went to
Spokane and Tulsa they both need people
to make stuff because there's like a lot
of [__] areas that are not that you
know great but uh you you this is cool
because it's cool but it's like one of
those places like in 10 years you it
might be cool it's like got four blocks
that's cool sure uh and it's not that
cool and then in 10 years it'll be cool
sure but it's yeah it's uh so anyway and
I played a theater there uh that used to
be uh owned by um uh and owned and uh
have KKK rallies there so anyway uh and
the person who the theater used to be
named after was a guy who was in the KKK
so anyway um and I didn't know that
until after I did this anyway um so no
but they also changed the name so it's
okay so anyway so but let's not fall to
everybody for their past
um
do you know what I mean totally yeah but
also
um
you could also have a conversation with
them this is something that I've done in
my own life
with difficult things to talk about if
you decide I'm gonna have the difficult
conversation and then it's kind of up to
them to decide what they're going to do
yeah with that right so you just say I
love you so much and this is what's best
for my family right now and then however
they decide to react to that is up to
them and so you don't have to feel as
guilty about their reaction because
you've done everything that you can do I
love you so much but going to Tulsa
what's this is this the is this the uh
voicemail
oh no do we not what's up prison
oh it's so long it had prison in it
though yeah he said what's up prison I'm
going to or something like that he's
going to prison I guess so
I want to try one okay let's try one
this is Patrick
I'm actually at the bar right now too uh
my question for you is why are our
attractions the weirdest thing by anyone
knows the girlfriend of eight years I
just legit just seen a lot of weird fire
attractions tonight
how can we solve that and have Humanity
not quality so antisocial not saying
that I'm the super I could start on the
planet because I'm not but just out of
curiosity I want to know what you had to
take about bar interactions and people
looking at each other at a bar
also the first show especially artwork
as I've seen in my life thank you very
much that's the artwork he's ever seen
on his life is that we said about my
show in Minneapolis that's nice okay we
like them oh wow he said best artist
he's ever seen his life that's what he
said wow okay I really like that guy
like a smash to [__] Smithereens for
real what was it so I came in a bar I'm
in a bar why is it it's so weird when I
have an interaction I have a girlfriend
like eight years so what's up what's up
there's a lot of looks in the bars or
something like that anyway say
Minneapolis best artwork I've ever seen
in my entire life
so love you guys both bye
just threw up and then slipped on it and
bonked his head and died oh that made me
a little nauseous just hearing it
well it's the best part you've ever seen
in your life uh yeah dude get out of the
bar you know or uh just [__] stop you
know toss it when you're out of the bar
you know what was the question why are
interactions so weird at bars
oh you don't even know because you've
never been drunk he's smashed this guy's
[__] exhilarating you've never I know
but he's blitzed
he's three sheets to the wind yeah but
that's not anything to do with what I'm
saying he's faded dude you've never been
drunk he is so funny
yeah anyway all right dude what up dude
tour ticket to chrisley.com he went to
Minneapolis and he said it was the best
artist he's ever seen in his life so
come on down to Ohio I'll be there I'll
be in Nashville I'll be in uh Montreal
and uh chrisley.com get the tickets oh
wait Tucson uh I got a question go to
watch lifeline.com or uh Lifeline merch
is at lifelinemerch.com or you can get a
one-on-one advice session with Matt
matalia.com mattelia will be back next
week we are firing her and getting
matalia back and I will be in my house
for the next uh nine months at least
seven years taking care of my two babies
who I love very much yes
um no but uh thank you so much you
covered for Matt and also it was nice we
did want to we did want to have you uh I
don't know we like having you on I like
having you on congratulations and it's
cool to have you on this one this one
seems more fitting
um but uh yeah anyway and thank God we
didn't have to ask [__] David
Sullivan so that's great that's great I
love you he's got a big head all right
cool I love you too and um
we'll hang out even more after this no
no no
that's what it is that's an inside thing
you don't know about she brought it up
and I'm pissed so
because I have the Flames I used to do
it 43 you know well to be fair I did it
when I was 40. so I was much younger oh
um but you guys
have a good time and like And subscribe
and leave comments about how beautiful
she is no babe
[Music]